ich habe mich ja von Anfang an also immer
gefragt bei dem März an wen erinnert der
dich an wen erinnert und dann bin
ich drauf gekommen Wilhelm Busch
Lehrer Lämpel
und dann [Applaus]
und dann adressiert der märz an die Ampel
den Vorwurf sie ist eine Schande wie unsere
Bundeswehr in den letzten Jahren
systematisch kaputt gespart wurde
früher man merkt schon dass du bisschen länger
raus warst aus dem Geschäft ne sonst wüsstest du
vielleicht wer 16 Jahre lang am Stück bei uns die
Verteidigungsminister gestellt hat das war deine
schwarze Bagage los geht's mit Franz Josef jungen
dem Hobby Winzer aus dem Rheingau schied Fritsch
der dann zwei Tanklastzüge in Afghanistan danach
musste gehen dann kam sein Nachfolger der geölte
der Lügenbaron aus Franken Karl Theodor zu
Gutenberg der musste dann auch gehen und sagt zu
seinem glücklosen Nachfolger demüsier ich übergebe
Ihnen mit der Bundeswehr ein gut bestelltes Haus
und hat nur gemeint kein Mensch käme auf
die Idee sich so ein Haus zu bestellen
Dachstuhl morscht die Wände schimmeln
kein Fundament dann war der Dümmel
sehr weg und dann kamen die beiden
allergrößten also allergrößtinnen
Uschi von der Leyen und Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer
die beiden einzigen Blendgranaten
bei der Bundeswehr die noch [Applaus]
funktionstüchtig war na wir haben viel getan
wir haben gleich zu Beginn haben wir ja unsere
Geheimwaffe in den Kreml geschickt unsere
Hyperschall Rakete weil alle gesagt haben ja
da ist eine der einen wie Putin die Stirn bietet
weil er hat genug davon Olaf Scholz und der hat
dann auch ordentlich auf den Tisch gehauen im
Kremmel nur bei dem Tisch und wenn ein stolz Haut
nein das war schon alles war ein Aufruhr
vorbei es gab auch Fans von Putin vorneweg
natürlich Donald Trump und Agent Orange hat
seinen Einmarsch in die Ukraine gefeiert
ein anderer Ex-Präsident aus den USA
der hat auch also den Angriffskrieg
verurteilt bis sie wollten eigentlich
verdammen hat sich ein bisschen vertan
da saß ihm wohl freut im Nacken
als er sagte dass dieser Krieg war
ein
Bruder Invasion
das gleiche also die Entscheidung eines einzigen
Mannes eine völlig ungerechtfertigte und brutale
Invasion zu starten Georgi Boy wo du
recht hast hast du recht er hat ja im
Irak damals auch genauso viele Massen
Vernichtungswaffen gefunden wie Putin
Nazis in der Ukraine Trump fand beides toll
und bei Trump sind auch viele schon wieder
der kriegt noch mal an was machen wir jetzt
wenn der noch mal und auch da kann man ein
bisschen locker bleiben und beruhigen der hat
ja ständig betont ich kandidierte zweimal ich
gewann zwei mal so okay dann befindet er
sich ja schon in seiner zweiten Amtszeit
und dürfte laut amerikanische Verfassung
gar nicht mehr antreten mein Gott aber Trump
ehrlich das ist ein solch verblendete Narzisst
das hat ja fast schon syrische Züge na gut
nein keine Sorge auf den auf den komme ich
auch noch aber wir hatten wirklich wir hatten
der Krieg in der Ukraine bei uns ging dann gleich
die Diskussion los oh haben wir das mit Russland
all die Jahre zu sehr auf die leichte Schulter
genommen haben wir das Unterschied waren wir zu
naiv natürlich wollen wir das na wir haben
gedacht 89 Mauerfall juhu alles super alle
freuen sich alle Pfeifen fröhlich wind of change
und rufen danke Gabi danke Gabi reicht doch das
vom Fall des Eisernen Vorhangs und dem Zerfall
der Sowjetunion vielleicht nicht alle Russen
so begeistert waren wie wir hatten wir in diesem
Jahr schön gesehen bei gorbis beschämen Begräbnis
und dann die große Frage wer ist schuld wer
hat Putin all die Jahre unterschätzt und da
war natürlich vielen klar wer immer schuld
ist die SPD alles war die SPD gut okay also
einen muss man da schon in die Verantwortung
nehmen also das muss jetzt wirklich nicht sein
Gerhard Schröder der Gastronomie aus Hannover
der oberste Russen verstehe uneinsichtig bis zum
Schluss von wegen bleibt mein Freund der Bloody
der hat doch einen Scheißdreck daher geredet im
es er hat sich im Kopf und Kragen da konnte man
gut sehen dass ein Hektoliter Barolo am Tag klarem
denken nicht unbedingt dienlich ist und außerdem
irgendwann sind dann alle auf Distanz gegangen
weil spätestens als er gemeint hat die Ukraine
möge die Ukraine möge doch bitte mit dem Säbel
rasseln aufhören verrückte die Parteispitze
endgültig von ihm ab zumal wir der Ukraine
noch gar keine Säbel zum Rasseln geliefert hat
weshalb deren Botschafter der geborene diplomat
gleich wieder gerasselt hat die SPD spielt so
hat dann ihr klingenbeil ausgepackt und gemeint
Gerhard Schröder das hat mit der Linie der SPD
nichts zu tun hat der wieder locker genommen oder
so mit der SPD und ihrer Linie und ihrem sozial
Gedöns da habe ich noch nie was mit zu tun gehabt
einige hatten trotzdem Hoffnung vielleicht kann
er was bewirken die verstehen sich doch vielleicht
keine ausmachen im Ukraine Krieg und er ist ein
extra losgefahren hingefahren nach Moskau und
seine Frau hat der weil einsam im Luxushotel mit
Blick auf den Kreml für Frieden gebetet es war
nötig habe ich mir gedacht weil wie willst du
mit einem wie Putin verhandeln wie willst du da
was erreichen also das schafft ja selbst einen
Schröder nicht um Putin loszuwerden da gibt's
eigentlich nur eine Möglichkeit und da hatte ich
im März einen ganz seltsamen Traum seit Gerhard
Schröder besucht seinen Buddy Wladimir geht direkt
zu ihm in den Kremmel ins Bernsteinzimmer lacht
sein kehliges wolfslachen zieht ein Feuerzeug aus
seinem brioni-anzug und meint guck mal Vladimir
was man mit so einem kleinen Zippo alles anstellen
kann wenn man unser Gast mal so richtig auftreten
zack bum ein riesen Knall der Kreml der bebt in
seinen Grundfesten wie ein mürbe geschossener
Wohnblock in Kiew Tage später tanzen die
Menschen auf dem Plätzen die Welt feiern
Schröder ruht ein balsamiert im Mausoleum am
Roten Platz direkt neben Lenin als Puzzle und
und die frisch gewählte DDR die Demokratische
Partei Russlands beschließt einen neuen
nationalen Feiertag den Tag des großen
weltenretters im ewigen Gedenken an
den Ehren Russen Gerhard Schröder
dann bin ich aufgewacht